so thank you everybody for coming so
first of all let me just take a little
poll how many machine learning experts
do we have here in the audience okay
good I'm not talking to you
unfortunately I'm going to be talking to
everybody else so how many deep learning
experts anybody who's not a machine
learning expert a deep learning expert
somehow okay that's good whoo that would
be interesting so a little bit of
background my name is Carrie naturally I
am a fellow technical fellow and
Symantec Corporation I'm an adjunct
professor at UCLA where I teach freshman
computer science and I really enjoy that
and about a year ago I had a new boss
that joined on to Symantec and he told
me you need to learn deep learning and
you to bring deep learning into
semantics which is where I work
full-time and so I said to myself okay
this is a challenge I'm not a
mathematician in fact I'm horrible I'm
horrible with math so I proceeded to
learn deep learning by working with some
friends and I thought this is a really
interesting topic and I somehow present
this to other people who don't
necessarily have a deep math background
so that you can understand deep learning
as well so my goal is not to go and give
you lots of complex mathematics and so
on but rather to give you a gentle
introduction with a little bit of math
so you can have an intuitive
understanding of what deep learning is
all about I am sure that I will offend
some people and what I say because I'm
going to be doing gross
oversimplification and so I apologize in
advance for those of you that are
practitioners do me a favor throw the
tomatoes after I'm done okay so I call
this deep learning for dummies because
again this is meant for everybody or you
know people with a very very limited
math background and I say like me
because frankly I'm not a practitioner
really I'm not doing a lot of machine
learning at Symantec right now frankly
okay so what's the goal of this talk to
provide you with an intuitive but not
necessarily mathematical understanding
of what deep learning is and why it
works ok and nobody's been able to do
that from ever had lots of papers online
they were very complex a lot of them had
typos in them they were just very
difficult to read so I want to give you
a very very basic understanding of deep
learning and why it works as I said I'm
not an expert norm a petition so you may
actually challenge me and I'll say
that's a really great question let's ask
Andrew Inc okay and then that'll be my
answer in many cases so what is deep
learning
well deep learning is a type of machine
learning and that you might say well
what is machine learning
well machine learning is a class of
algorithms that can automatically learn
concepts through automated analysis of
large amounts of information and data ok
so we want to learn concepts and then
further use those algorithms and use
that understanding of the data to solve
problems like recognizing a person's
face or driving a car or understanding a
spoken command thank you very much ok
so deep learning is a special type of
machine learning it's a it's a subclass
of machine learning where the machine
learning the deep learning system learns
or discovers layers of increasingly
complex abstract concepts about whatever
it's looking at whether that be a voice
signal or an image whatever it happens
to be so increasingly abstract concepts
about the data it's trained upon so for
example and this is taken from Stanford
paper you know a deep learning system
might be trained on a bunch of pixelated
data just raw black and white or color
pixels ok and that might be the input to
the system and then the system will
identify one set of concepts that hey
the images that I've been presented with
actually have edges and curves and so on
that are actually present in many
different images that I've seen ok so
the deep learning system will learn this
and then it will actually take these
regularities that it observes these
things that sees across many of the
images or pieces of data that's
presented with and you'll say hey wait a
second I can actually compose
higher-level concepts based on these
simple things that I found within the
data and then from there it can actually
take these you know simple pieces and
then say oh I actually see combinations
of these and therefore it can actually
discover all this on its own so we're
going to learn how from the fundamentals
deep learning actually does this so
because deep learning algorithms
discovered these increasingly abstract
abstract concepts automatically ok
traditional machine learning that that's
why this is interesting ok that's why
we're deep learning is so exciting so
traditional machine learning approaches
when I first started doing some neural
networks and decision trees way back
when you have to go and analyze the day
to yourself by hand ok you have to go
and say Oh
for instance we use this for spam
detection ok we had to say oh they're
these
interesting keywords are used in spam
and these keywords are not used in spam
and then we have to identify those as
features that we're going to use and say
well if I see this and this then it's
probably not spam and if I see this and
this is probably the spam so we have to
identify features but the neat thing
about deep learning is it discovers
what's important automatically actually
figures out what is relevant to the data
that it's looking at and it doesn't
require humans to go and program that in
whereas traditional machine learning
approaches we had to extract and
identify the features ourselves in many
cases okay now I'm going to be taking
you from back in the 1920s to seminal
work that was done and how that let
leads up to deep learning and so you
might say when you start seeing the
beginning of this talk how does this
relate to machine learning and
processing images and understanding that
as a cat an image and the answer is just
please bear with me try not to fall
asleep I'm going to show you a legend on
the top of the slide and we're going to
start back in 1920s we're going to end
with the human brain and you'll see a
little box around here and that's how
you know where we are within this talk
okay so bear with me there's a punch
line the punch line is right about there
okay and we're going to get to it and
it's going to be it's got a little bit
of build up there okay so there's a
there's a legend right there you can see
it at the top of the corner of the
screen and let's start okay so deep
learning automatically is able to learn
things about the data find abstract
concepts multiple levels of abstract
contact concepts and the information
that it looks at and it all goes back to
the Ising model so Ernst izing was a
physicist that was looking at magnetic
dipoles and basically doing simulations
of you know a bunch of atoms within a
lattice okay and he was working for will
homelands who actually came up with the
Ising model and I guess I don't know why
they call it the Ising model not the
lens model but they were working
together in 1922 and there we are you
can see we're just starting right there
and so what Ising was studying was he
was basically saying can we model a
series of atoms which are either flipped
up or down okay like you know for
magnetism they flipped up or down and
how they interact with each other okay
and so what might the atoms look like
well you can see that some atoms are
pointing up and some atoms are pointing
down okay and these atoms will vibrate
over time according to some rules some
principles okay and they actually have
some connections in between them
themselves that will govern how they
actually flip around and so on and this
is what he was doing he was trying to
model if I have a bunch of particles
how will they interact with each other
will there be for instance stasis will
they you know they did get into a stable
state or will they flip-flop or
oscillate and so on okay now in the
Ising model there are weights in between
these atoms okay and you might think of
these weights as a connection or
strength in between for instance this
atom in this out okay now each way
indicates how strongly two atoms are
correlated and for instance a highway it
would indicate the two atoms should be
pointing in the same direction in fact
this would be an unstable state because
a score of 99 would indicate these two
atoms should really be pointing the same
direction on opposite directions think
of like a spring and if you twist it it
wants to spring back into the its
original state okay and so we would
expect this atom may be flipped like
that okay now a state you know for
instance a weight of 1.0 would indicate
well you know there's some correlation
but very little correlation between
these atoms and over time we would
expect these atoms to flip imagine if
these were just random atoms and they're
flipping there's a cosmic ray that comes
in how would they flip over time and so
on that's what we're talking about here
and he was saying how could we simulate
this how can we model this okay and so
you can see these atoms are definitely
highly correlated they're flipping a lot
this atom over here might flip randomly
once in a while less correlation to this
guy here okay and oh they flipped again
now some of the weights can be negative
so for instance this weight here might
be negative 50 and in fact this would
indicate that these two atoms are anti
correlated in other words they should be
pointing in opposite directions okay so
in this case here if these atoms were to
flip we'd probably see something like
that right in other words they're all
going to stay in sync because these two
atoms are highly correlated these two
atoms are anti-correlated they're going
to flip back and forth okay so they're
always going to be sort of opposite each
other
generally okay that's the probability
that they're going to flip opposite each
other now the atoms experience peer
pressure to flip as well so for instance
let's imagine the weights were 500 and
300 so this atom is facing up this time
is facing up these are very very strong
interactions here that would cause all
things being equal probabilistic higher
probabilistic chance that this atom is
going to flip to face the same direction
okay however that
said ultimately anything can happen this
is a probabilistic model anything can
happen
this atom in the middle could just flip
back it's possible that it could just
flip back and oh there it goes and it
flips opposite okay so this is the Ising
model and basically you can model any
sort of set of atoms with different
weights in between and what Ising was
was a studying was lattice models so he
was basically studying for instance
models of atoms in a square lattice with
various weights now let's look at this
model
I've actually constructed a simulation
which I'll show you which is a little
happy face it's not exactly like this I
couldn't fit the whole model on the
screen so I'm showing you basically this
is a happy face and what I'm showing you
here is that these atoms have higher
correlations with each other in other
words a very high correlations the ones
on the sides have very low correlation
so they're going to flip flop a lot more
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
just let these atoms sort of vibrate I'm
going to let them vibrate and simulation
there's we use a sigmoid function if you
know what that is in order to go and
decide whether the activate there's a
random number is generated and we
basically let them flip and flop and
vibrate based on these these particular
weights he'll hold on one second and
hopefully you'll enjoy this okay here we
go let's make that bigger what you see
out there yeah what do you know okay so
there you go there's my happy face okay
now you notice that it's not actually
showing a complete happy face we see a
nose there and we're about to see it
probably a part of a mouth may be
showing up ooh there's sort of some of
the mouth you can see it's sort of
standing out there so the fact that that
I have these weights that are sort of
tying atoms together doesn't mean
they're necessarily going to flip in the
same direction again it's all
probabilistic oh there's a mouth there's
a nose let's see if we get a get an eye
in there before it's oh there's an eye
and I notice the eye happens to be
standing out it happens people let's say
a positive spin versus the you know
negative for the no loop there that goes
the nose standing out you get the idea
okay so it's just a simulation of atoms
flipping up and down and up and down
probabilistically according to the
weights okay so let's keep going here
all right I'm already losing some people
and getting some sleepers I take
pictures of sleepers and then I post
them on the Internet
okay so
let's take our Ising model now every
configuration of atoms okay
and weight has a specific energy okay so
there's something called energy
associated with these systems and let's
talk about the energy okay
so let's give each up facing out on a
score of plus one and let's give each
down facing atom a score of negative one
okay and this is part of the model
now atoms I'm sorry and between atoms
we're going to call these weights as I
said so there we have weight zero one
basically from from X 0 to X 1 we have
weight 0 1 from X 0 to X 4 we have
weight 0 4 and so on so you can see
there are weights for each of these
between each of these atoms okay now if
we want we can compute what's called the
energy of the system here in this case
we have 4 atoms and we can compute
actually 5 atoms and we can compute the
energy of the system and the energy of
the system is simply as follows we sum
up that value 1 times 1 times that
weight plus that value times that value
finds that way and so on ok so basically
we're summing everything up let's see it
and we actually take the negative sign
so the energy is considered negative ok
so we take it we have a negative sign
there so watch this so in this case here
we take one times one times one point o
plus 1 times negative 1 times negative
50 okay and then one times negative one
times one point oh and one times one
times 99 we sum it all up and we take
the negative of that okay so there's our
energy function and what we find is and
based on the theory low energy
configurations are those in which atoms
are connected and and basically pointing
the same direction when they have high
positive correlate positively okay so in
this case here for instance notice that
these two atoms are aligned okay these
two are lines so that's good that's
actually a negative energy state it's a
very low energy state it's that's the
way it wants to be it doesn't want to
flip from that state it's actually good
okay and similarly if I have atoms that
are anti aligned or anti-correlated and
they have a negative weight that's also
a low energy state that's the system
likes to be in the state it actually
likes to be in the state ok and these
configurations tend to be more stable
okay now high energy configuration
that's
low energy configuration a high energy
configuration is one in which atoms that
have a high positive weight are actually
anti-correlated so look we have this yes
here two atoms that are actually facing
opposite directions and yet they have a
high positive weight or here we have two
atoms facing the same direction with a
negative way these would be
anti-correlated and this is an unstable
system these atoms just like a spring
that you've sort of turned the wrong way
is going to want to spring back the way
it started okay so pairs of atoms with
positive weights tend to be anti aligned
in a high energy system these are
aligned if they have a negative weight
these are this is also high energy and
what you will see is in this type of
system that you're going to actually
have a flip and it's going to try to go
into a low energy State and you'll go
from a plus 149 for instance to a minus
149 and that's the system will naturally
do that probabilistically it's going to
go overtime and vibrate to an to a lower
energy state okay so let's consider an
Ising model with three atoms okay now
three just three and one two three there
are three possible states of those atoms
it can be up up up up up down up down up
and so on all right just the binary
states so here we have three atoms all
up you know down up up sorry
up down up and so on and there are the
eight states and we here we see weights
of minus $15.99 so imagine this these
three atoms can vibrate through these
eight different possible states okay
they can even be in any of these eight
different possible states okay now okay
here are the energies of these three
atoms okay so if the atoms are facing up
up up the energy would be minus 49 a
negative energy which is good it means
it's reasonably stable but not nearly as
stable as this configuration here with a
energy of minus 149 where the atoms are
more again sort of the way they want to
be okay now if we take this system here
and we started it up up up and we just
let it vibrate in other words it's going
to vibrate cosmic rays are going to hit
it we're going to simulate this what
we'll find is that this first
configuration x1 up up up okay
it occurred once now let's sort of
vibrate and see what it does oops well
that went down that was down up up and
then that was X 2 and then X 8
configuration X 8 came about then we let
it vibrate some more and X 2 happened
again and so on and if we let this
vibrate over time we're going to build a
histogram of every possible
configuration this can be in
now with just three atoms there are only
eight possible configurations and we can
actually watch this over time for a
million iterations and we're going to
see it a nice histogram of sort of what
state it's going to stay in if you had a
million atoms there would be two to the
million State okay so it would be very
difficult to actually measure this
empirically Alika try it be sort of
interesting but in reality we're just
measuring this for just you know eight
different states for three atoms okay
but in a real system like for instance
one you might use to learn or you know
you know with millions of atoms
you really can't measure this okay now
this histogram here okay what you notice
is that low energy configurations low
energy configurations like this 149
where the atoms that with a positive
weight are facing the same direction and
negative weights are facing the opposite
direction they tend to occur more
frequently in our histogram which makes
sense right they are lower energy we're
let more likely to vibrate to them and
similarly high energy configurations
configurations with a very high energy
are less likely to occur not infinite
you know they might they're they're
going to occur occasionally I mean it's
possible a cosmic rail hits something
and you're going to vibrate to that
state in this case here we didn't
vibrate with our little limited sampling
but we probably would but just at much
lower frequency okay and that's as
expected okay now the probability of
vibrating to a given configuration X sub
I to the configuration X - like for
instance down up up for example is
predicted by this formula okay so the
probability of vibrating just 2 X sub I
whether it be X 5 or X 7 ok is e the you
know obviously two point seven one right
to the negative energy of that state
okay so we know the energies of these
things so it can be either the my you
know minus 1 49 over the sum of all the
energies for all the possible states now
if I only have 8 possible States it's
possible that empirically you know
compute exactly what that denominator is
but in most cases if you have a million
atoms you're not gonna be able to
compute that denominator okay so we're
going to have to do this mathematically
but in this case I literally could add
up either that put either the de minus
that plus e to the minus that plus the
minus that and so on to get the
denominator and I can now compute the
probability that any particular state
will come up
okay so the more negative if you notice
X sub i's energy the higher the
numerator will be okay
and therefore the higher the probability
of the configuration actually popping up
more often hopefully that makes sense
okay and so now we could if we wanted to
empirically sort of measure the
probability of each of these
configurations popping up on in our
three atom series okay now for
simplicity for the rest of the talk I'm
going to call this sum this equate value
here e to the minus energy X sub I of
weights okay and by the way the energy
again includes the direction these atoms
are facing and the weight values that's
what X sub I and W are okay we're going
to call that en RG for now and so we can
actually write this equation in a
simpler way of saying the probability
that the system vibrates to one of these
eight configurations is the e energy of
that configuration like 149 you know
divided by the sum of all energies okay
so hopefully that makes sense we can
continue and by the way if you've heard
of it this is called the Boltzmann
distribution Boltzmann I believe was
around and I think 1868 and Boltzmann
was studying you know basically if you
have a bunch of a system with a bunch of
moving parts how often will that system
be in any particular state how often
will two atoms be up versus one down and
one up and so on and that's basically
the Boltzmann distribution okay so this
is the distribution for this set of
eight atoms okay now what if instead of
having weights on a plane so in other
words 2d a 2d lattice like we saw with a
happy face what if instead we had
weights between two adjacent planes okay
so this is what we have before we had
positive and negative weights with atoms
of various spins up and down and what if
we switch from that one-dimensional or
other two dimensional approach to one
that's a three-dimensional approach we
have a visible plane there it is okay
and a hidden plane okay so now we have a
visible section and a hidden section
think of this plane like a touch screen
not only can it display something in
other words the the the direction of the
atoms think up for instance an op
direction as being a non pixel in and
down Direction being an off pixel for
example okay but it can also potentially
influence the
if you touch it you might influence the
state of the bottom plane okay so the
bottom plane can influence the top the
top can influence the bottom now in this
case you don't have weights in between
items on the top plane and you don't
have weights in between items on the
bottom plane but you have weights
between the top and bottom plane only
okay only okay so for instance that
neuron or let's call the neuron right
now because actually we're going to go
there but that your that node right
there or neuron right there is connected
to these four nodes here with you know a
negative way there and positive weights
there and so on okay and for example
that node right there that item right
there is connected by those weights and
in general every atom on this plane is
connected to every atom on that plane
okay this is a 3d Ising model now atoms
on each plane turn are now only
influenced by atoms on the other plane
in other words this atom no matter what
its value will never influence this atom
directly because there's no direct
connection here there's no force there's
no spring between these two atoms okay
so for example if this atom here for
instance happened to flip okay the only
impact would be on these atoms here not
on the atoms that surround it and these
atoms might flip in response to that
atom flipping okay and similarly if this
atom here were to flip for example then
the only ounce would be impacted would
be atoms up here not atoms down here and
for instance we might see these atoms
flip okay so the connections are between
the planes not not inter plane okay now
in such a model energy is computed a bit
differently but it's it's analogous okay
and the energy is now basically the
following okay double summation okay
basically what we're doing is we're
taking every visible atom and every
hidden atom and we're saying for each
visible the hidden combination and the
weight between them we're going to sum
them all up okay so let's give you an
example here for instance to compute the
energy we can take v1
there's v1 there's a visible atom one
okay there's hidden one there's hidden
atom number one and there's a wait
between visible and hidden atom atoms
one okay so there's weight one one and
we can basically some multiply those
together and sum that up with V 1 H 2 so
we'll take visible 1 and hidden two okay
and the weight between 1 & 2 will sum
that up and so on ok so now we can
complete compute if you will the enter
of this entire system okay we can do
this one yours v9 and there's h4 visible
the hidden and there we go we take the
wait nine four and we would sum that up
now just like before if we have a
visible atom and a hidden atom that are
connected by a way okay and it's a
positive way okay and they're facing the
same direction notice both facing up
that would be low energy that's a low
energy state okay and similarly for
instance if we had a visible and hidden
atom facing in opposite directions okay
that would be a with a negative weight
that would also be a low energy state so
these are the low energy states they
just between visible and hidden layers
now and that's before configurations
with lower energy okay are going to
occur with higher probability than those
with high energy and when I say
configurations I mean of all the atoms
both of visible and the hidden planes
because now they're dependent on each
other okay so so if we want to compute
the energy of a configuration once we
find that we can also find the
probability of a configuration occurring
so for instance we might ask what's the
probability of the system vibrating to a
particular 3d configuration so for
instance what's the probability of this
system vibrating - up up down down up up
up down down you know up up down up okay
that we can ask that question and we can
actually compute that by computing the
you know computing the the probabilities
using the energy model we talked about
earlier okay and so the answer to this
is the e energy of the configuration e
to the negative energy that we talked
about before of the whole configuration
divided by the total energy across all
possible configurations you know if we
in this case here we have nine by and
for 13 atoms so 2 to the 13th power
total configurations we could sum up all
the energies and that's how we figure
out the likelihood of any particular
state this would be in and what and we
can also compute the probability of the
system vibrating to a particular visual
configuration okay now how do we do that
what do I mean by that we can say what
are the odds that the system will
vibrate to exactly that visible state
okay irrespective of what that hidden
layer is we don't care where that hidden
layer is we just want to know what's on
the touchscreen what's what's on the
monitor that's what we want to ask
what's the probability of vibrating - up
up down down up up up down down okay we
can ask that and
irrespective of what those Evans look
like and we can compute that as well and
the way we do that is obvious basically
we say okay
the probability of this configuration
here okay
displaying the visible configuration V
is the probability that we display this
given these are all facing down plus the
probability of displaying this given
these are all down and one is up and so
on and so on we go through all the
combinations of all those bottom atoms
and sum them all up and that's the
probability of displaying the top the
top visual display there okay so you get
the idea we can compute the odds that
this system will vibrate to any
configuration like a volt top and bottom
or we can give you the odds of the top
only the visible plane will vibrate to
some configuration irrespective what the
bottom looks like okay so just as with
our 2d Ising model we can pick weights
to buy a certain configurations of atoms
so for instance remember I showed you
the happy face I pick some weights well
we can do that as well
so for instance we can positively
connect upper left hidden atoms okay
the upper upper this this atom right
here let's forget about these for the
time being let's commit this guy here to
the first call okay and we'll connect it
with green means positive correlation so
high positive weights we can connect
this to the third column with green
lines meeting high positive weights and
if you're hopeful you're not colorblind
we could also connect it to the even
columns with negative weights so this is
red that's a red color and we can do it
there with a red color and so there'd be
negative weights for these so now we
would expect okay we would expect that
that atom would be positively correlated
with those two columns in other words
it's going to flip in the same direction
together and we would expect that atom
would be negatively correlated in other
words flake flip in the opposite
direction for those two columns
hopefully makes sense okay and so we'd
expect our top layer to either be
stripes in other words first row all the
way up and this is a third row all the
way up if this is up and then the other
ones down and so on so let's see what
happens there
oh let's there vibrating oh look at that
that one's aligned with that one that
row in that row or that column that
column that's anti-aligned
if we let it flip again ooh look they're
still aligned so aligned these are sort
of anti aligned and we let it flip again
and of course it's not perfect look at
that that atom there decided to get out
of line it's not you know it's not
really playing ball but that's okay
that's possible okay and so on so these
are
to keep flipping and so on and they're
going to generally be aligned because of
the positive correlations now why is
this the case why are we seeing this
well let's imagine we have our hidden
atom here and let's we're only dealing
with one hitter now if the hidden atom
just happens to randomly flip up
okay let's imagine it happens to
randomly flip up okay OOP there it goes
it flipped okay it is going to influence
okay positively correlated item
correlated items in the visible plane
and they're going to flip up as well or
they're going to have a higher
probability flipping up because they
have positive connections they have
Springs that are sort of in the same
direction right so they're going to flip
up like that okay now and similarly
let's just imagine that items atoms on
the top plane happen to randomly get hit
by cosmic rays and they happen to flip
around like that watch okay so maybe all
three of them are flipping down well
those atoms will have a strong effect on
the bottom hidden atom as well and so
what we would expect to see is that if
these guys flip they're going to cause
him to flip because most of them are
flipping the same direction and he's
going to go and say well I don't want to
be in an opposite direction I want to be
aligned I have peer pressure here okay
and so this will further reinforce
alignment on the plane so we're going to
have alignment between the two planes
if this happens up they're going to tend
to be up if this atoms down they're
going to tend to be down if these happen
to randomly flip most of them over 50%
up then he's going to randomly flip up
as well and so forth okay so they're
going to be aligned with each other so
what this is is a semi stable system
it's or maybe a bi-stable system right
in this case is by stable they're either
all going to be aligned up or although
I'll line down most of the time
occasionally they'll go and flip
opposite each other okay so this creates
a self-reinforcing set of stable
configurations now in fact we say that
our 3d Ising model that we show here is
a generative model and for those of you
that don't know what a generative model
is we call a generative because if we
allow the system to vibrate so this atom
flips wherever it would flip and these
atoms respond because they're connected
by those ways when they flip and so on
then we're going to naturally tend to
generate patterns on the visible surface
that are based on the specific weights
connecting the two planes so whatever
those weights are they're going to
influence or bias the system to vibrate
in a certain way okay and in fact we
would expect to both
distribution okay with two peaks okay
the first Percy
on Collins on you know up so on up and
even down
okay the second peak would be even up so
even up and a lot down because if this
guy is facing down then we're going to
have on down even up and if this guy is
facing up we're going to have on up even
down hopefully that makes sense okay so
we would expect this to be a bi-stable
you know configuration where we could
actually go and flip-flop into either of
these it might be possible that we
actually flip-flop into some other state
as well that's that's a lot it's you
know somewhat close and so we'd love to
vibrate this system is going to go from
sort of even all you know up-down
up-down or down-up down-up back and
forth back and forth this is going to
sort of vibrate between these states
with high probability and it's almost as
if it's daydreaming the system is
daydreaming because it's actually it's
reproducing what it knows it's actually
going into these states over and over
again that it knows and so think about
when you daydream you think about the
things you know you think about the
images you've seen before right you're
just basically going it you're you're
you're late and I'm drawing the analogy
for a reason you have your weights in
your brain and those will influence how
you think about what you think about
what images you see and so on it's
analogous in some ways we think so
talking about daydreaming let's see an
example so here are here's a demo and
there are five atoms on the bottom and
there's a visible plane so here's a
visible plane your touch touch screen
here are the five hidden atoms and I'm
going to go and connect manually I'm
going to do this on my own each atom to
various atoms here on the top visible
plane so I'm going to connect hidden
atom number one to those sets of atoms
right there okay so I'm going to
basically have strong positive weight
connections between that atom and those
sets of atoms I'm going to have the next
atom connecting to that middle one oh
noes the next atom connecting to part of
the mouth the next atom connecting to
part of a happy face grid and the next
atom connecting a part of a sad face
let's see what happens okay
so here we go
oh look at that look at that happy face
oh look at that now he's not in the
other happy nor sad okay so this is just
the random vibration of the system a
pound sign is an atom that's facing up
okay
an empty song empty space is an atom
facing down and you can see the system
is vibrating I think it's going to go
negative it's going to go through a
phase change where the eyes are actually
going to become negative let's see if
that happens maybe not come on let's see
let's see maybe the nose so you can see
it's great oh I guess not okay well
anyway you get the idea we can influence
common state of the system so that they
basically occur much more frequently now
notice that system of atoms could have
turned into a cat it's just very very
unlikely because we have these weights
that really influence it or bias it to
become a happy face or sad face okay so
oops okay so by manually adjusting the
weights we did it manually actually did
it by hand between the two planes we can
basically bias the distribution of what
images are going to show up we can cause
it to daydream in a manner that makes me
happy okay now there was an aha moment
okay where the 3d IC model becomes the
restricted Boltzmann machine so
basically okay here we have the Ising
guys and back in the early 1920s and
they're studying how these system of
atoms vibrate and all the relations
between them and so on and what the
energy states are and then two guys come
around and there are lots of people
involved so don't tell me if I were you
can tell me afterwards that hey these
weren't the really the guys there were
other guys you know there's there's a
hot field and all these other people who
were involved in this and we have to
give them credit but let's talk about
Geoffrey Hinton and Terry Sejnowski to
really sort of launch this field I would
argue and they had this idea and they
said hey let's use a simulation of an
Ising model let's seize an Ising model
simulation on a computer to encode
memories to encode memories let's live
to teach these atoms to learn about
memories okay so in the early 80s Hinton
sidao ski started experimenting with 3d
Ising models so remember the two planes
we just talked about and they called
them or where they're called restricted
Boltzmann machines or RBMS so maybe
you've heard of our RBM it's really just
a two plane set of ice of Ising model
with connections between the two planes
but not between each plane
not intraplate and their goal is to come
up with an algorithm that could take a
blank RVM network so just all random
weights you know written value all
values of one weights let's say okay so
random weights and then teach the
network by modifying its weights how to
encode a memory okay so it would
reproduce for instance a happy face
image so instead of manually typing in
weights like I did where I actually said
between here and here there's a possible
plus 100 weight what they did is they
said can we somehow learn automatically
how to reproduce a happy face okay so if
allowed to vibrate once they learn these
weights notice they're green and red now
the RVM would vibrate up this encoded
image more frequently than other images
that that was our goal okay so I'm going
to show you a possible communication
between the two of them so Hiten says
Terry I wonder if we can train a 3d
Ising model to remember a picture and
then Sadowski says to remember a picture
this is probably how it happened right
and then Terry says are hidden says I
want to be able to pick an arbitrary
image and he goes oh there's my image he
sort of dreams it in a bubble okay and
he said and he says and then find some
automated way to pick the weights of the
Ising model so that when it vibrates it
shows my picture more often than it
shows other pictures okay so it vibrates
more often to my image rather than other
images okay and he says I see well as we
know Ising models naturally vibrate to
low energy configurations right we they
vibrate they will tend to vibrate two
configurations that are more low energy
or lower energy okay and so all we need
to do is pick a set of weights that
causes our desired image to have as low
an energy as possible okay so if the
image if we pick a set of weights such
as when those weights are present and
when an image is present the image we
desire the system's energy is very low
that image is going to show up on that
visible plane more often okay and see
says right then our Ising model will
naturally vibrate more often to our
image will actually train it will give
it memories okay so they use what's
called a gradient descent algorithm
which many people spend copious
dissertations on which we won't talk
about but it's a very interesting
algorithm or set of algorithms that
solve a problem and what this problem is
is they figure out the right set of
weights given something they need they
need to optimize for okay so
they what these guys want to do is they
said okay here we have our 2d or 3d
Ising model we have a we have to
determine the weights between layer the
visible layer and the hidden layer such
as the energy for this image is as low
as possible and this image will likely
vibrate up so they take this in they
stick in that black box okay and let it
run see the gears are running it's very
exciting it almost looked like that I
think when it really happened there and
then it comes out with a set of weights
positive and negative ways okay that we
will use in order to connect the visible
and hidden layers okay okay now the
resulting Ising model is a generative
model okay so what does this mean again
once we've computed these weights with
our gradient descent algorithm if we let
the system vibrate and Adam goes on here
and Adam goes off here on here off here
vibrate vibrate vibrate just called
Gibbs sampling what will happen is that
this will this image will more probably
show up on the visible platform or plane
than other images okay that's that's
what they try to do okay and ultimately
why is that the case because these
weights create a low energy state when
this image is actually displayed on the
visible plane okay so these weights were
chosen such that when that image is
shown that is the lowest energy State or
one of the lower energy states of the
system okay so if you remember our
Boltzmann distribution where we
basically did the histogram and we
counted how often things happened how
often we were in various states of three
atoms for instance okay we can compute a
Boltzmann distribution for these atoms
as well okay and basically what we're
going to do is we say okay this image
once we've run our gradient descent
algorithm should occur more frequently
than any other image ideally okay in
other words if you're letting the system
vibrate the probability this is a
probability distribution is that it's
going to vibrate to that image more
frequently other images now it's really
not a bell curve like this because in
the case of let's say 100 atoms there
are two to the hundred states right the
VG items can be into 200 straits off off
off off off off on blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah right so this can be in
many many different states so it's
probably going to be a very flat curve
with the middle in this image being more
probable than other images but still
very very unlikely okay now this image
here which is maybe with a little part
of the eye missing is going to probably
go
over there on the curve in other words
it's going to occur more frequently than
other images but it's going to less
frequently than the image we were
trained on and here's another image with
you know part of the mouth missing and a
spurious atom on there and that would
probably be over there let's say and so
you can see we're going to vibrate more
frequently the things that look like our
happy face with a happy face being the
most probable once we've run through a
gradient descent algorithm and then
things that look totally unlike what we
trained on are gonna have a very low
probability of occurring or lower
probability of occurring okay and this
is because the weights are picked in
order to have a low energy when this
item is present when this visible
configuration is present okay so what is
actually happening to our weights during
the gradient descent algorithm okay well
let's imagine for a moment that we only
have a single hidden node a single
hidden atom and we want to train to
learn this training image we want to
vibrate to that training image well as
you might expect our gradient descent
algorithm would like positive weights
okay positive weights you know positive
correlation to all atoms that need to be
on in the image okay so for instance
that atom is going to have positive
green weights to every atom that we want
to be on and we think that the great
ascent algorithm will do that it's gonna
actually that's what's going to end up
doing okay and we'll have negative
weights to every atom that should be off
and this will be a bi-stable system
right in other words you're going to
flip positive or negative everything the
happy face is going to be on or it's
going to be off in the background will
be you know on or off okay so this will
by bias vibration of the system two
configurations representing the tray
resembling the train image and why is
that because in those random cases where
this atom flips on right what's going to
happen is it's going to influence the
atoms on the visible plane and they're
going to flip on two and similarly if
for instance the visible plane happens
to go into a configuration okay like
that which is sort of close to a happy
face but not quite that's going to cause
activation of the hidden atom probably
it's in other words it's going to push
that atom to go in a line and that atom
aligning and going in the right
direction is then further going to push
this towards its desired state so what
we're going to do is it's almost like
we're rolling a marble down a hill we're
going to go get closer and closer to our
desired image because anything close to
our desired image activates this atom
which then activates the rest of the
network to get closer and so on
okay so they did that they said okay we
can go and train our Ising model to
vibrate to a particular image more often
than not and they say and then hidden
said what has hit and say okay we know
how to go and train an Ising model to
learn a single image okay he says but
what about training it on three images
or a million images is there some way we
can take that Ising model the two planes
a 3d Ising model and have it vibrate
more frequently to three different
images than to any other image that we
haven't trained on and he says why not
instead of using gradient descent okay
to basically optimize for a single image
why don't we use it to optimize for
multiple low energy states so right now
we're using it to optimize for one image
let's use it to discover a set of
weights that create multiple low energy
states so we actually have three right
in other words this is higher
probability than things around it this
is higher probability and things around
it and so on and you can actually use a
gradient descent algorithm or a gradient
descent algorithm to actually do this so
now we can actually make our Ising model
so that it is it vibrates there's a
higher probability that will vibrate to
one of these three states and other
states okay there's still some
probability it will vibrate to other
states as well okay so he that says
you're saying it's possible to find a
single set of weights that will create
multiple such low energy points and he
says that's correct if you have enough
atoms or weights the system can
represent multiple low energy states
right 3 in this case low energy states
or a million for instance okay so
intuitively how does this gradient
descent algorithm and this is where you
really need a pay attention if you were
sleeping wake up discover see look what
we're getting to the exciting part here
okay how does it discover a combination
of weights that creates multiple low
energy states that's the question
this is the fundamental question behind
deep learning in my mind and we'll see
why it's relevant okay so here we have
training image 1 training is 2 training
image 3 wakeup okay now notice that some
atoms in our 3 training images and there
might be a million training images but
let's just imagine we have 3 notice that
some atoms and our training images are
actually consistently on across all of
our images okay so let's go just flash
them up there okay well look at the eye
atoms notice that in the first two
training images the eyes are the same
and the third image even those two the
diagonals are on in the in the third
image right
and there were there consistent atoms
that are actually on across multiple
training images okay so the all three
images have those two atoms on all three
adages have those two atoms on all three
images have those four atoms on and so
on make sense okay so our gradient
descent algorithm identifies these
regularities irregularity being
consistency across multiple training
inputs multiple images for instance you
know the eyes are the same across
multiple images okay and what it does is
it ties them with strong positive
weights to hidden atoms so it'll pick
something hit my hidden atom we don't
know how it does it but in other words
there so in order to minimize the energy
it's going to pick let's say that hidden
atom and it's going to say ah because
these atoms were on across all of my
training images or many of my training
images I'm going to associate this
hidden atom here to those visible atoms
there and similarly it might pick that
hidden atom there and associate it with
those two visible atoms there because
they are on frequently okay and then it
might associate that atom to the node or
the nose atoms er okay and it's going to
similarly tie atoms that are off
frequently across multiple images with
negative weights so for instance it
might tie everything for instance to
that you know all the things that
shouldn't be on basically these this
pixel this atom is off in every single
image it's going to tie those to an atom
with negative weights for instance okay
now why would it do this why would it do
this okay now associating a positive
weight between a hidden atom a hidden
atom for instance that I'm there okay
and one or more visible atoms so here's
our visible plane that are frequently on
okay so notice these two atoms are on
here okay they're on there they're on
there and they're on there those same
two atoms are on across all the images
associating a hidden atom with those two
atoms that are consistently on or on
more out more often means at any time
the hidden add-on activates wants you to
activate their flashes okay anytime it
activates there's a good chance or a
better chance that it'll also activate
those visible atoms right in other words
if there's if this activates and it's
positively correlated with those visible
atoms they're going to activate as well
okay and guess what those atoms are
useful in reconstructing our training
image right in other words there are
useful in reconstructing all three
training images if those two atoms
activate we're getting much closer to
one of our desired images actually
vibrating up onto the surface that makes
sense
crazy and if that makes sense maybe want
me to repeat that yeah no we're good
okay okay so similarly for instance okay
so this atom activates it's going to
activate those two visible atoms and by
the way that actually is very useful
because those visible atoms are present
in all my images I wanted to train on
and so therefore there's a higher
probability that one of those three
images will show up and if I didn't
activate those common atoms okay so this
increases the odds that one of my
trained images is going to vibrate up on
the visible surface so the gradient
descent process this process of figuring
out the weights for multiple training
inputs identifies regularities common
clusters have activated visible atoms
okay common clusters have activated as
well atoms that are across multiple
training inputs multiple training images
and it ties them with positive weights
to or hidden atoms okay it associates us
with stronger weights to the various
hidden atoms so far is a good example
this hidden atom is associated
potentially with parts of eyes that are
frequently required for us to display
our images and the gradient descent
algorithm will figure this out I'll say
oh if I basically pick that Adam and I
tie it with strong weights to those
there's a higher probability the lower
energy of the entire system
of that part of the eye actually showing
up which gets us closer to our overall
images showing up okay or similarly this
hidden atom might be tied to for
instance parts of noses or you know the
nose itself if it's very simple okay and
why is this well guess what if this atom
activates then there's a high
probability of the nose will activate
and that's what we want because we want
noses to activate because all of our
training inputs have noses okay so the
great descent algorithm will naturally
find okay these regularities that will
cause a higher probability of certain
elements of the picture showing up and
associate them within that and in
practice these identified regularities
will be very simple they're not going to
be an entire nose they're not going to
be an entire eye but they might be an
edge they might be a little curve okay
they're going to be very simple
and it's this exploitation of
regularities that causes our RBM to
vibrate more like more often too it's
learned images than to non learned
images because basically that's what you
know it's basically there's we identify
the things that are frequently seen
across multiple images we reinforce
those positively and we're more likely
to vibrate to those okay so in essence
or RBM is gaining an intuitive
understanding of the images that's been
trained on now let me give you an
analogy here because maybe I'm still a
little bit maybe it's about making too
much sense or maybe it is I don't know
imagine if I have a chef and the chef is
very susceptible to brainwashing and I
just you know I'm feeling like some
Italian dish okay and I know most
Italian dishes have some pot some tomato
sauce in them so imagine if I put some
tomato sauce on the counter in the
kitchen and I just sort of watch the
chef and goes oh tomato sauce maybe I
should make an Italian dish right that's
what we're talking about here we're
identifying common elements of many
different Italian dishes and we say oh
that's tomato sauce and we say hey let's
go and bias the probability that we're
going to have an Italian dish made
because we're putting tomato sauce on
the counter similarly there's your
tomato sauce
there's your Italian dish okay okay so
our RBM is learning what features are
common across the universe of it of
images it's seen it's like they're
actually this this process where we use
gradient descent is actually saying ooh
tomato sauce is actually common to all
these Italian dishes I'm going to put
tomato sauce on the table that's going
to be hidden neuron number one and
that's going to bias production more of
Italian dishes now here's where things
get really interesting because once
we've trained your RBM and a bunch of
images okay what would happen if we were
to manually flip our visible atoms to
one of our training images and hold them
steady so let's go flip we already have
the weights here so we computed all the
weights or you know we did it
automatically by the way for our three
images or a million or whatever we
wanted to do and we then basically flip
up the atoms or in yellow and flip down
every other atom
okay so we're basically configuring that
visible plane so it's in a certain
configuration and we clamp it there you
say you're not allowed to vibrate okay
no vibration but we allow the hidden
atoms to vibrate
okay now as you would expect the hidden
Avram Adams are going to go and vibrate
and they're going to activate based on
hey look at that there's a there's a you
know ratatouille or whatever so
therefore we're going to go and vibrate
that I'm on because there's our there's
our pasta or tomato sauce note okay so
what's going to happen is a set of atoms
in the hidden layer are going to vibrate
on based on activation from the visible
layer make sense okay so in essence the
resulting hidden atom configuration you
can think of it as a code that describes
the scent of regularities that were
found in the visible image okay so for
instance if this atom turned on that
would mean that the image appears to
have part of a left eye Oh interesting
okay well that's interesting and for
instance if this atom turns on that
means it appears to have a nose okay so
basically when we clamp this and
activate this this this tells us what
regularities what commonalities occurred
within those images okay and this
appears to have part of a right eye for
instance so the hidden atom
configuration therefore represents a
high level description if you will of
the original image it is sort of a
description of the original original
image okay okay so let's take our train
RBM that that two layer system the Ising
model okay
so we have all our weights we computed
those weights for our three images and
let's take each of our training images
okay our 3 there could be a million but
let's just take three now and let's go
and clamp them onto the visible surface
we're going to clamp that happy face and
that happy face with a full eye and then
we're gonna clamp the other happy face
the sad face actually on there and we're
going to allow the hidden layers to
react as they would react okay so in
other words activate whatever they would
activate based on what they see in the
visible layer okay so now we have three
high-level descriptions of each original
image okay okay and we can actually
gather those up so let's do something
wacky something crazy and wacky okay
let's create a second restricted
Boltzmann machine a new restricted
Boltzmann machine that's completely
blank okay there it is has a bunch of
great weights they're all random weights
okay and let's use gradient descent
let's use that algorithm we talked about
and let's pump in these high-level
of those images the one that says oh
there's part of an eye and there's part
of the mouth and there's part of the
nose let's pump those in and train a new
restricted Boltzmann machine okay so you
can pepper pump those in and train and
identify a set of weights for this RBM
okay so we'll pump those in we're going
to use the gradient descent algorithm
with the gears that we talked about
earlier
okay pump those in pump those in and
then we're going to learn the weights so
that this restricted Boltzmann machine
vibrates - these three visible
configurations more often than other
configuration make sense in other words
once you train this RBM to vibrate it's
going to vibrate - one of these three
images as opposed to other random images
because that's what we taught it to do
okay so these specific configurations of
atoms are going to vibrate more commonly
more often on the visible plane and as
before to do this we need to find the
regularities across these images right
in other words the restricted Boltzmann
machine when we train it fundamentally
the way that we cause it to vibrate to
these items more than other items is by
finding the common regularities in these
sequences that are that you know and we
want to go and associate them with
hidden atoms they're going to cause
those things to pop up more frequently
okay so what does this look like okay so
what we have here is we train our new
irbm
it's visible atoms don't represent raw
dots in other words these atoms here
don't represent the raw dots in in a
pixelated display like we had in our
original example these represent looks
like there's an eye looks like there's a
right eye look like there's a nose and
so on not raw pixels of black and white
pixels right so as we learn these atoms
represent more abstract concepts right
that for instance that atom there might
represent part of a left eye okay and so
therefore that atom there now represents
part of the left eye and that atom there
might represent part of a nose or you
know for instance okay and that atom
there therefore represents part of a
nose so when we train our second RBM
when we use gradient descent what
happens is that it will discover
regularities in these inputs not in the
original set of inputs but in these
inputs and it will associate those with
hidden atoms and this will discover
higher-order relationships it'll say ooh
all three images have that left animal
and I better cause that to activate that
means all of my images have an eye for
instance okay so for instance
this atom might activate when an image
has two eyes okay and so for instance it
might be tied to that atom layer which
is associated with right eyes and that I
don't know it's associated with left
eyes and now if this goes on well then
it turn both those on because all the
images we saw I had two eyes and so it
figures that out and it actually encodes
that in this RB M so there's an
interesting intuition because we can
repeat this process over and over every
time we add an RBM we can train a new RB
m okay it's going to learn successive
levels of abstraction about the images
or inputs that it's been trained on okay
so for instance here we had a black and
white screen right we had images which
which were pixels are either on or off
okay at this layer we learned that we
were able to represent simple facial
features like a part of an eye and
hidden Adam might be connected via a
positive weight to a part of an eye that
was common across many of the images
right at this layer maybe this
represents facial components in other
words you know two eyes together okay or
an eye on a nose for instance and this
layer here we might actually represent
entire faces okay so basically for
example when that and that activate that
might represent a happy face with hair
okay which would activate for instance
this atom here in this atom here which
would activate these atoms and so on
okay and so we can actually go six seven
eight ten levels deep if we need to and
discover increasing regularities about
the data at increasing levels of
conceptual sort of a what's the right
word that's traction okay so for
instance these atoms might be a Sat
girl's face okay and in fact and here we
can see from Andrew who's probably not
here right now but you know some of his
research he starts by pumping it on this
layer here a black and white image maybe
with some some great grayscale this is
what this layer detects it detects
simple simple edges because those edges
are present in many different images
says ooh look at that there's a
regularity if I go and activate this I'm
going to see this you know I'm going to
cause this to occur more frequently on
my visible plane if I vibrate
here we come combined these edges in to
get even more abstract concepts like oh
you know these are actually associated
in a certain way to produce an eye and
then we can actually produce faces when
we get to the bottom layer
okay so notice that we're actually
getting successively abstract or
learning things about our images or
inputs whatever they are so this network
is called a deep belief Network a deep
belief network it's basically a stacking
of restricted Boltzmann machines so
stacking of restricted Boltzmann
machines starting with just ones and
zeros if you will okay and once we have
such a network we can do all kinds of
interesting things with it
okay so for for example we can take an
image and we can basically fix it in
place we can clamp it okay and then we
can see how level atoms in the next
level activate which represent again
sort of parts of edges and facial
features and so on and then how atoms in
that level activate that might be sort
of you know this edge and this edge
makes sort of part of an eye or
something and how that last level
activates and so on okay and what we can
do is if a train with enough input
images the deep belief Network can
actually learn to recognize common
elements in those images in other words
it's going to say you know what I saw a
million images I was trained on and
there was a thing that looked like a cat
face in all of them okay and this node
or rather that atom might be associated
with a cat face and in fact if you look
at Google's deep was a deep brain I
figured what they called it they
actually without telling the system
anything about what a cat looks like it
actually learned that this neuron
represented a cat and if you were to
actually take this neuron and sort of
propagate back up it would actually show
you a cat on the visible layer it
learned this without being told that a
cat was or anything else because there
were so many cat videos they trained the
system on millions of pictures of cats
and YouTube videos that it actually
learned a sort of a you know iconic
picture of a cat okay without ever being
told what a cat is
okay and by the way sort of interesting
if you basically take this network and
you let it vibrate between these two
layers so I just let it vibrate no no no
no right let on off on off based on
those weights and after a while after a
while vibrating you then propagate that
back up you're going to get
stereotypical images that sort of come
from your distribution of images that
you train the system on it'll actually
daydream cats and dogs and trucks and
whatever people you know beaches and
whatever people have trained the system
with in our case it would be happy faces
sad faces sort of really happy faces and
so on
okay now with a bit more coding we can
actually determine which atoms in the
bottom layer activate for each type of
input image okay
so for instance we can say oh all the
images that have a happy phase have
these two atoms activated and therefore
this is associated with happy faces you
can use machine learning other
techniques on this in order to say ooh I
just saw a picture of a happy face right
we could build a classifier so basically
after pumping in millions of images and
the system sort of gets an intuitive
understanding the regularities across
all the images all the edges and so on
we can then pump in all those images
again get the bottom output so let's hit
that bottom hidden layer and that would
be a description of every image you know
might be Oh a person that might be hair
that might be an ozone that might be
able to face a math curled up and so on
and basically we can actually compute if
you will what what combinations or types
of combinations would be associated with
happy people or sad people or trucks or
cats or whatever and now you could pump
in an image potentially and recognize
ooh there's a cat okay now you can also
deal with noisy inputs okay so what if
you have for instance a signal like
somebody's voice which is a little bit
noises knowing the noise in the
background or you have an image which is
sort sort of noisy it's a grainy okay so
Matt should I pump in an image it looks
sort of like a face well guess what
because most of the atoms are there
that's going to that's going to tend to
activate the next layer in the same way
so we're going to activate the same
atoms that would be activated generally
if if it were a proper image we're going
to propagate that down and propagate
that down we're going to say oh I was
just presented with a picture of a happy
person and then you could propagate that
well you can you can sort of recognize
things that are noisy in other words if
it's close enough the atoms in each
successive layer are going to activate
and we're going to be able to identify
that in fact we saw something that we
recognized so it doesn't have to be
perfect the inputs don't have to be
perfect or for example we can
reconstruct so imagine I take a face
like this okay which is sort of half
there and I propagate down a clamp it
and I propagate down propagate down
propagate down and then I propagate back
up I say move okay well this is what
activates it looks a little bit like a
happy person if i propagate it back up
and then see what actually is visible on
the visible layer
I can actually get my original happy
face so it's going to say like you know
I I know what that looks like and I
mostly activated now I'm going to
activate backup and it might be a little
bit more complicated you might probably
get back down vibrate around here a
while doing Gibbs sampling and then
propagate back up okay and you'll see
this actually works it's very
interesting you can give it a partial
image that actually puts it in a
particular state which is close to what
it wants to be in and then if you
vibrated a bunch it'll go back into the
right state and you can use this to
detect anomalies which is interesting in
computer security that's what we're did
in this for at least one thing okay we
can take an input image like that okay
and propagate it down through our
network now remember this network was
trained and happy faces the only thing
has ever seen or three happy faces let's
say okay but we'll take this image that
basically doesn't look at all like a
happy face and will propagate this down
and we'll see what atoms activate now
remember these weights are associated
with with images of faces not with that
crowd of atoms there but will propagate
it down okay and we say seems to be
there's a nose in this input image and
it seems there's like a mouse in this
input image because it doesn't know all
it knows is faces so it's just sort of
getting these atoms activated and you
know it basically you know goes all the
way down and then if we propagate back
ah we say okay well let's clamp this
down and let's probably get up well
those atoms would activate those atoms
activate and guess what it says oh that
looks like a face and part of an eye or
part of a nose or something right this
is what it thinks it saw because as far
as its concerned it's only seen images
of faces and this is about this is about
as close as it can get to that basically
based on its activations now if you
compare this image to this image and
they're wildly different it means the
images are anomalous in other words the
image you presented it does not look at
all like what it was trained on it's
nothing like what it's seen before on
the other hand if I presented it with
selling that look mostly like a happy
face and it came back with something
that looked mostly like a happy face I
could say ooh this is something it knows
about and so you can use this for
computer security you can measure for
instance normal activity on a system and
if you see abnormal activity and you
pump it through one of these systems
then you would expect to see that the
output if you pump it back up will look
not at all like what you the input would
be okay we compared the input the output
images and say
wait a second they don't look at all
alike but if you happen to pump a face
in there it would look very much alike
okay so if our output significantly
differs then this is a strong indication
of unusual input and so those are you
speak machine learning notice I didn't
classify anything I didn't have to have
any supervised learning I didn't have to
say this is a picture of a cat or a
happy face or anything else I literally
pumped in images I said Network learn
how to optimize for this image learn how
to vibrate to this image by picking a
set of weights and that's all I did
and it figured out the rest now here's
the kicker so we again we even literally
pumped in raw data into our restricted
Boltzmann machines we did it multiple
times on multiple layers and it figured
out the rest these gradient descent
algorithms figured out the rest
most traditional machine learning
approaches require an engineer to do an
expensive extensive amount of feature
extraction so they basically required
you to say oh I'm building a network
about on faces every face has an eye and
eye and nose in the mouth so I'm going
to go and build an eye detector and I'm
gonna have a one Adam if there's an eye
and another one if there's an ally and
it one for our nose and so on you have
to do any of that the system just
figured it out okay so we don't have to
do any of that it just figures out the
the information so what are some recent
wins we're almost done here
so Baidu recently announced a deep
learning system deep speech that used
massive amounts of data okay to achieve
roughly a 29 percent improvement in
speech recognition with two weeks of
work so I literally took some existing
components off the shelf they built a
system you know and they pumped in 100x
more data than ever had been pumped into
a machine learning system before our
deep learning system before and these
other systems here from Apple and then
Google and so on they have they are very
complex systems millions of lines of
code that are DTI they transform the
input signal in different ways they look
for phonemes and sphenoid bone names I
don't phonemes there you go okay they've
all kinds of crazy stuff this system was
literally what I showed you literally
converted into a frequency domain or
whatever it was they trained a bunch of
restricted Boltzmann multiple levels
deep actually use what's called a
recurrent neural network okay
and they actually achieved you know
error rates look at that error rate
unclean unclean you know no clean means
there's not a lot of background noise on
you know clean speech recognition about
six point five six percent error rate
okay versus for instance you know the
best
before was 6.64 and that had lots of
hard-coded very specific stuff in it
okay in noisy environments okay they
achieved a nineteen percent error rate
just pumping in data and this this type
of approach versus all the existing
systems that are really really hand
optimized to solve this problem and they
did it in two weeks two weeks Microsoft
Research recently published an image
recognition result that achieved four
point nine four percent on the top five
error rate I don't know how many people
are familiar with image net okay this is
good this is all I'm getting to the
right group of people hopefully so
there's a database of millions of images
or mono exactly how many images it's
called the image net and they're all
classified so somebody actually went
through and did a classification of
everyone there's a might there's a
person in a convertible wearing a straw
hat okay and so on okay and the goal of
this compensate competition is to
basically take a subset of the images
and train on them for instance build
those restricted Boltzmann machines we
talked about okay okay
take the rest of the images and see if
you can guess what's in those pictures
now five ten years ago we would have
looked at this and said there's no way a
computer system could fit configure
outdo computer vision and figure out
what's in an image I remember when I was
taking computer science at UCLA they had
pictures of blue balls on grey
backgrounds and it was difficult to even
figure out was a ball with a vision
system right these systems okay
basically when we say top five error
rate there are five guesses the system
is allowed to get for each image okay so
for instance the Microsoft System can
say I think it's these five things these
are my five biggest guesses my five
highest probability guesses and if you
get one of them right okay then you're
you know you basically you're doing okay
Microsoft achieved a four point nine
four percent error rate on this which
means that 95% of the time roughly the
guests that they made was in one of the
top five guesses was right okay they
guessed it was a might and they guessed
it was a container ship and they guessed
it was a you know a smarter scooter
ninety five percent of the time and
guess what the established human error
rate is five point one percent this
actually does better than humans using
deep learning yes how many of those
three top guys four top guys they're
basically
Sharon wants it back yet I don't know
like I can't tell you that that's a good
question because maybe there's a there's
a reason why they all did this out
that's right yeah I don't know I mean
there's only different up that you would
guess that at least thought they did
some different difference on the speech
engines for your clothes possible yeah I
don't know that's my best answer and I'm
sticking with it Facebook which is
actually an older result but Facebook
actually they built something called
deep phase which did a little bit of
processing they actually took a face if
they only had half a face they would
actually use the half they saw to
project a symmetric copy of the face for
the other side or to produce a you know
face from the front and then they
trained their system on faces it
achieved in ninety seven and a quarter
percent effectiveness rate of saying you
know given faces that it's been trained
on give it a new face identifying
whether you know hoop long - okay
the current sort of human L accuracy is
97 point I think five three percent so
we're getting really close to this stuff
and this doesn't require a lot of crazy
you know a lot of crazy pre-processing
they did some they did some but these
other results are you know very simple
okay so one of the catalysts for this
why have we seen this explosion recently
we have we you know we had we had you
know hidden and so on Sadowski doing
their work in the mid-2000s but why have
we seen an explosion recently well in
2006 as we said this really you know
Geoffrey Hinton really kicked off kicked
off this revolution I would say okay he
wrote a paper fast learning algorithm
for deep belief data was it was sorry
for a deep belief I can't read the last
word there I don't remember the title
that's embarrassing hold on let's see
that's deep leaf notes okay and this
basically described effectively using
our VMs in this way okay and doing
what's called green layer wise training
so what's greedy layer wise training
this is where we trained one RVM at a
time so we trained one RBM we used we
use the gradient descent algorithm so
the weight can cause the visible plane
to display what we want more frequently
than the things that we don't want and
once they did that and they got these
hidden layers defined they went a one
more layer deeper and they went one
layer deeper and so on okay now why was
this actually really interesting because
before we had
neural networks that look like this
we've had neural networks that look like
this for 30-40 I don't know 50 years a
long long long time multi-layer neural
networks okay but nobody could train
these neural networks effectively all
the way through okay and there are
various reasons for this there are
mathematical reasons like for instance
when you do back propagation and you
actually try to compute these weights
there's errors that that basically
explode in the network as you go in or
actually diminish your deltas as you
change the weights actually go up or
down and you end up not training the
neural network effectively if it gets
too deep so what his contribution was is
he said hey let's do greedy layer wise
pre-training let's train a layer at a
time we'll get that right once we get
that right we'll do that and get that
right and once we do that we'll get that
right once we do that we'll get that
right and then guess what you can do one
pass through this whole system and
optimize it even more because it's in
the ballpark now that we're training
each little layer it's in the ballpark
and this was what kicked everything off
because previously we didn't have the
computing power or the or the math in
order to to do this the other thing that
came since then really is huge and
computing power increases so GPUs these
graphics cards that we use for mining
bitcoins and playing video games are
really really good at deep learning
algorithms because deep learning
algorithms are primarily using you know
matrix algebra it may trick you know
like linear algebra right and so GPUs
are literally thousands of times faster
than traditional CPUs and so we can do
far more calculations and for a very
cheap price and so well this allowed us
to do is it optimal us to optimize
bigger networks bigger networks that can
actually process more data do solve more
interesting problems okay
and the other thing that's really that
really was an accelerator is the
Internet has provided so much more data
you know crowd-sourced data whether it
be from Google searches or images you
put on YouTube or chat voice chats you
do on Facebook or whatever it happens to
be actually don't know Facebook mine's
at but lots of this data is being mined
and if you use it you just pump in huge
amounts of data data is king or queen
okay
the more data you have you can train
these systems to do virtually anything
and that's what we saw with the Baidu
result right just by pumping in a
hundred times more data into a
traditional system it was able to learn
these regularities okay so if you
combine you know this sort of you know
this sort of intuition here
we can do a layer at a time to start
with more computing power well guess
what now and there's a debate about this
it's not obvious that layer wise
pre-training where we actually do a
layer a time is the best way to solve
this problem because we have so much
computing power now and we have some
algorithms that we can actually run
because we have so much computing power
that we can actually train these
networks straight through okay and so
there are advances in machine learning
for instance how do we initialize the
weights if you initialize the weights to
all kinds of random values then the
network actually may not converge on the
right set of weights to actually
maximize the probability of things
vibrating up right but if you initialize
the weights in special ways you can
actually cause the system to actually
get more closer to the optimal
configuration and so a couple of better
computing power the algorithms that we
couldn't have used before because they
were too expensive for instance we knew
how to do a lot of these things we can
now effectively train these networks
straight through you know not all not
one at a time one layer at a time but
just all the way straight through and in
fact some of the best results are
training networks straight through just
using some of the newer results or newer
approaches and some old approaches that
weren't feasible before this computing
powder and data were available okay so
right now is actually a it's a
hatfield-mccoy war a big Indian versus
little Indian war of whether you do
layer wise treat pre-training or whether
you train the thing all as one big
network multiple layers deep so one last
thought and you see them on the brain
now we're literally done in one second
here have you ever thought how amazing
visual memory is I mean before I started
studying deep learning and again you can
tell I'm an amateur right I mean this is
not this is not my area but it i I think
this is the single biggest most
interesting result
I was wondering how can I remember
images from when I was literally 5 years
old because all of us remember things
from when we were young remember things
from yesterday we see a menu remember
things from it we see a dish or a
birthday cake do you think that our
brain basically stores high-level
snapshots like literally multi multi
pixel snapshots oh sorry
let's do that again of cats all the cats
you've seen on YouTube you think that
your your brain is literally storing
like you know a thousand by a thousand
pixel images somehow and your neurons
probably not right maybe not maybe
what's happening is that we have visual
receptors that are finding
some simple features okay we have
another layer of neurons that are
identifying regularities across the
things that we see right so oh a cat a
cat a cat all of them have a eyes that
look like this and whiskers that look
like this regularity regularity we have
a set of neurons a layer behind or maybe
our visual neurons and then another set
of layer of neurons behind that ooh two
eyes are together usually with cats okay
that neuron is going to activate four
twice and what if the encoding of
memories is actually a multi layer okay
multi layer you know approach just like
we saw with these Boltzmann machines in
other words you have some cat neuron in
your brain or maybe a set of cat neurons
okay and when you see a cat all the
images all the elements of the eyes and
so on are going to activate that cat
neuron okay and when you encode a
picture in your brain you're not
encoding a thousand pixel by a thousand
pixel image or 4k by 4k image you're
encoding hey that picture that I
remember had a cat in it and it had
grass in it that neuron that neuron
activated will maybe have some
connections between them you're encoding
very low sparse information very little
information that can represent that that
you know the original image that you saw
so an image can actually be stored
potentially with very little information
if you already have built these
structures in your brain that represent
these regularities okay and think about
when you daydream where do you daydream
you daydream the things that you sort of
know you've seen before you daydream the
stereotypical cat okay or maybe somebody
if somebody's face you've seen many
times so this could explain why given a
memory cue you can set it remember
remember a whole image right remember we
saw I showed you I could give it a
partial image and because I'm going to
activate those atoms that are related to
that image goes all the way down boom I
activate some some neurons there and
then I process it back up and I say oh I
remember what that was right that would
explain that when we're viewing a
partial image your brain can visualize
the rest if I see part of somebody's
face I can visualize what the rest of
their face looks like okay or when you
see something unusual your brain knows
it immediately when you hear a pun you
know there's something funny about that
pun or do you see something an image a
cat on the moon you're like wait a
second cats are never on the moon I
don't have any I don't have any neurons
that represent a cat on moon rocks
together but I do have neurons with a
cat on grass together okay
so you can recognize anomalies you can
picture them in your mind's eye and
after seeing hundreds
cats as a kid okay pictures of cats cats
walking down the street cats on YouTube
for people who grew up the YouTube era
and you never knew what they were called
you just saw a cat Cat Cat Cat Cat Cat
Cat I see all cats from every angle and
then suddenly your mother or father says
that's called a cat and you instantly
know what all cats are because now
you've just associated a term a
vocalization with that mother neuron of
a cat or mother neurons and you now know
what cats are think about that because
you're not associating the term cat with
every high-resolution image of a cat
you've ever seen through your visual
cortex
so in conclusion deep learning is a
machine learning technique that works by
learning multiple levels of abstraction
about its inputs ok the regularities the
things that are common across its inputs
once the deep learning system learns the
inherent structure of its inputs you can
use it to classify items to reconstruct
partial inputs to detect anomalies to
search for related items we didn't even
talk about that but you can actually use
this to search right ok find me all
things that look like this picture of a
cat on the moon you could do that or you
can just daydream with it these networks
literally you can let them vibrate this
was a most fun time I had when I was
building this just I built these
restricted Boltzmann machines and I
would let the system vibrate now I would
actually do I was doing this on the emne
Stata base which is a bunch of numbers
or handwritten number and the system
would actually just dream up numbers
that it seen before and they didn't look
like the numbers they were training on
they were sort of close but not quite
they were you know sort of combinations
of numbers that it had seen before just
like you daydream these systems daydream
they vibrate up and they will show you
on their visible display what they think
and finally the engineer doesn't have to
do lots of pre-processing to apply this
to problems you can literally pump in
raw data in many cases and get results
and finally this is a sales pitch if you
enjoy this talk I just finished off on
your novel it's going to be a veil on
all the major sites on April 14th and
all the funds are going to charity so
take a look enjoy it I think you'll
enjoy it's a cyber thriller techno
thriller and it's for a good cause so
thank you
you